[Musique]
et le temps passe vite
passé où tous les manguments de toute
leur lunule septembre l'accoucheur de
cyclone octobre le flambeur de Cannes
novembre qui ronronne au distilleries
c'était Noël qui commençait voici venir
le réveillon de Noël la viande de porc
qui sera reine sur les tables en sauce
et pour la farce des pâtisserie reste
l'un des produits incontournables des
étals des marchés pour préparer les
succulents mai de cette fête familiale
c'est le moment en effet de se procurer
les ingrédients indispensables à
l'élaboration des recettes
traditionnelles lesquelles feront le
bonheur des palais durant la nuit du 24
au 25 décembre
cependant face à une inflation estimée
entre 4 et 5%, les prix pèsent
lourdement cette année sur le budget des
ménages mais après deux ans de
restriction sanitaire et d'une vie
sociale en berne la cause de la pandémie
de covid 19 les martiniquaises sont
déterminés à profiter de la magie de ce
Noël 2022
qui ont pas de programme ou bien qui ont
juste envie d'être bien quoi ben la
maison est ouverte chacun vient avec
quelque chose ou pas on prépare à manger
et puis et puis il y a des jouets pour
les enfants une petite pensée pour
chacun et puis c'est la joie d'être
ensemble en fait
presque on aurait presque fallu que Noël
tout le temps pour qu'on puisse être
ensemble et fêter ensemble c'est ça
l'esprit de Noël en fait alors moi Noël
pour moi je suis invitée c'est une amie
qui est toute seule et toute seule et
comme nous sommes tous les deux seuls
donc j'y vais avec elle 24
pour moi Noël c'est une fête de famille
c'est une fête où on passe avec sa
famille et les amis voilà c'est ça alors
je n'aime pas les fêtes de fin d'année
autant je suis très carnaval mais je
n'aime pas les fêtes de fin d'année
parce que c'est le moment des bilans des
choses comme ça et je n'aime pas ça par
contre comme j'ai des enfants et les
petits enfants obligations je tâche
qu'il allait manger chez une copine le
24 et puis retourner gentiment chez moi
par contre le lendemain
tradition oblige entre le Rago sont les
points d'Angolais etc je t'ai acheté de
me soumettre à la tradition le nom de
mes 24 ans l'état pas spécialement
de se retrouver de passer un bon moment
et puis bah de se dire que l'on s'aime
qu'on s'apprécie
Noël c'est une fête de pinçage une fête
de famille donc obligatoirement ça va se
passer en famille et avec les amis et on
n'oublie pas les enfants qui attendent
effectivement les enfants les petits et
les grands d'ailleurs qui attendent les
cadeaux de Noël et puis bien sûr le
partage du repas traditionnel de Noël
avec le cochon les pois d'Angole les
ignames en fait tout le Noël
traditionnel de notre belle Martinique
Martinique merveille du monde
dans la religion chrétienne les
festivités de Noël célèbrent la
naissance de Jésus de Nazareth dans une
étable à Bethléem en Palestine au
Proche-Orient pour respecter la
tradition une crèche est installée et un
sapin et dressé une pratique initiée au
12e siècle dans une église italienne à
l'époque les habitants du village
étaient réquisitionnés pour incarner les
personnages de la Nativité puis petit à
petit ils ont été remplacés par des
figurines en plâtre ou descendant
provinceaux donnant naissance au crèches
vivantes que l'on connaît encore de nos
jours Noël est aujourd'hui la fête la
plus populaire auprès des petits et
grands fidèles pour ces catholiques
c'est un moment d'amour de partage et le
bonheur d'être ensemble après deux ans
de pandémie comment l'Église catholique
d'ailleurs le temps lui-même dit tout
l'avant pas avait à Na v e n t le temps
de l'avènement le temps l'avènement donc
il faut préparer cet avènement de Dieu
dans son cœur c'est venu il est venu
donc il faut préparer son cœur il vient
il faut préparer son cœur il viendra il
faut préparer son cœur donc cet
avènement se prépare dans son cœur dans
ses vins que à Noël il y a nos chanter
Noël tout ça mais c'est d'abord une
démarche intérieure le temps de l'avant
on est en violet d'ailleurs qui est en
train de conversion une démarche
intérieure pour reprendre la bonne
direction dans sa vie on va dire qu'à
Noël une naissance cela fait de la
naissance de Jésus c'est l'occasion de
nouveaux dépens donc le chrétien le
croyant est appelé à prendre un nouveau
départ dans dans sa on imagine un
nouveau départ dans la bonne direction
un nouveau départ dans la bénédiction
donc il faut faire le point sur soi et
c'est un point qu'on fait dans la joie
parce que si on prend la bonne direction
et ben on est dans la joie de reprendre
la bonne direction un nouveau départ
tout est possible alors Noël 2022
c'est un Noël de sortie de confinement
mais c'est aussi un Noël de
avant de sortir une crise ou encore de
traverser de crise plutôt et donc c'est
un Noël qui nous propose au milieu de la
crise au milieu de difficultés d'avoir
la paix au fond de soi-même c'est-à-dire
de se poser de se reposer on vient de
sortir d'une période on va dire de
persécution par rapport à la covid on a
besoin de se poser il y a des crises
familiales des crises en société des
crises entre les peuples de la des
guerres des des remises en question
globale et mondiale sur la question de
de l'écosystème de l'échappement
climatique de la pollution mais on a
besoin de s'apaiser c'est possible
aujourd'hui au milieu du tourment de ce
monde au milieu du désordre au milieu du
bruit parce qu'il y a beaucoup de bruit
aussi au milieu de toutes les paroles et
de toutes les propositions de se poser
enfin et de se dire que Dieu il est là à
l'intérieur la véritable institution
c'est celle là hein c'est la présence de
Dieu à l'intérieur
parmi les différentes activités
proposées pour l'occasion par l'Église
catholique de Martinique figure entre
autres un rassemblement avec l'avènement
de la Croix de la lumière
[Musique]
samedi 17 décembre place Roméo face à la
cathédrale Saint-Louis de Fort-de-France
les catholiques avaient déjà commencé à
célébrer la naissance de leur Dieu une
manifestation laquelle s'est ajoutée aux
autres actions menées par le diocèse
durant l'année 2022 l'église dont je
suis le pasteur en particulier et qui
prépare Noël depuis ce qu'on appelle le
dimanche de Christ Europe pendant 4
semaines il y a des textes bibliques
qu'on médite pendant plusieurs semaines
évidemment comme tout le monde nous
faisons des cadeaux comme tout le monde
préparons les repas et les réveillons de
le réveillon de Noël ou les festivités
puis aussi de façon avec un peu de
générosité même beaucoup pour les plus
pauvres pour les nécessiteux bien
entendu qui sont au cœur aussi de la
fête de Noël faut pas l'oublier
ouais c'est la Renaissance d'abord du
temps c'est aussi quand vous dites
Renaissance je dirais renouvellement
renouvellement de nos relations aussi
une relation de famille c'est peut-être
le moment de se réconcilier c'est le
moment de se concilier avec soi-même
vous serez concis avec Dieu de se
réconcilier avec l'existence avec avec
la société aussi qui est Lourdin les
lourdes elle est difficile à vivre pas
simplement guère et épidémie mais toutes
les tous ceux dont on entend parler les
conflits les scients les oppositions les
profitation etc Noël c'est le moment de
retrouver un esprit d'enfance pas idiot
au contraire avec une regard très
perçant sur l'existence sur le monde
puis en même temps la joie quoi le
savoir être joyeux c'est une très belle
science
le port quant à lui termine son année à
l'abattoir après avoir été bien nourri
plusieurs mois auparavant le rituel
commence par la mise à mort du cochon
ensuite son sang est récupéré pour la
préparation du boudin puis l'animal est
rasé ou gratté soigneusement pour le
débarrasser de ses poils avant son
lavage sans fumage et son dépeçage la
Noël d'un temps
dans une comme le gourmande c'est la
ruralité n'a rien à voir avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui alors il y a plusieurs
étapes dans la préparation de Noël déjà
pour mes trucs c'est à dire que pendant
il y a des pleurs il y a des pleurs des
enfants pleurs parce que pendant un an
deux ans pour faire grossir le cochon de
Noël on a donné dans un bail à manger au
cochon pendant x temps mais on sait pas
si le cochon avait lu son horoscope pour
Noël puisque il doit passer à la
casserole et les petits enfants qui fait
ça tout le temps après l'école à
l'époque à manger des poulets cochons
pleurer parce que il connaissait le
destin de cochon qui nourrissait
aujourd'hui par exemple pour faire le
parallèle ils ont centralisé sur
l'abattoir
au Lamentin à ce moment-là il faut payer
il y a tout un principe on doit plus
tuer son cochon soit disant puisque
exceptionnellement je pense qu'on peut
tuer le cochon mais c'est pas pareil les
anciens font souvent références à cette
période pendant laquelle les hommes
tuaient et vidaient le cochon de ces
viscères pendant que les femmes
préparent les gâteaux boissons sirop de
groseille penche coco et autres liqueurs
tels que le schrob une spécialité
antillaise mélangeant le rhum à des
écorces d'orange quant aux enfants selon
certains témoignages il jouait au ballon
avec la vessie de la bête et à plusieurs
étapes pas pour le cochon flambez gauche
mais oui il faut préparer les feuilles
de banane puisqu'on a gratté gratté soit
si c'est l'abattoir c'est un grand bac
d'eau chaude
les gens
on voyait que les poils restaient donc
ils apaisent bon mais en tant que gamin
ce que je vais faire le Flandre
pour faire le ballon et on souffle
dedans avec une tige de Giraumont pour
et puis de l'abattoir même
et aussi et
encore donc de café sur Skype
de nos jours les conditions d'hygiène
ont évolué et l'abattage du quadrupède
est encadrée il s'était annoncé d'abord
Noël par un picotement de désir une soif
de tendresse neuve un bourgeonnement de
désir un précis pour garantir aux
consommateurs la qualité de la viande de
cochon créole le PNL le parc naturel
régional de Martinique conduit depuis
2015 un programme expérimental baptisé
valeur parc naturel régional de
Martinique cette démarche s'inscrit dans
le cadre d'un élevage d'exception selon
le parc avec une alimentation saine et
une traçabilité des animaux
la démarche entreprise c'est de
caractériser la race où en faire une
race banditée une bête qui vivait
en liberté et qu'on a mis où on essaie
de structurer une production voilà donc
c'est un cochon qui a une croissance
lente mais avec
une viande qui a on dit dans cette
viande que les persillée c'est-à-dire
que on a un gras mais pas un lard épais
mais un gras qui sera intramusculaire
qui va rendre cette viande goûteuse
alors je peux dire qu'on a un son
positif
tout le temps ils disent que c'est le
cochon qui connaissait avant et qu'ils
sont prêts à avoir ce cochon à payer
pour avoir ce cochon de qualité donc on
a un bon accueil pour lancer cette
action des cochons sauvages ont été
capturés et des protocoles de gestion
pour l'alimentation et la conduite
spécifique d'élevage des bêtes ont été
préconisés par l'INRA l'Institut
national de recherche pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et l'environnement en
accord avec le PNL des éleveurs
indépendants et la chambre d'agriculture
nous accueillons une population pensive
donc qui est à l'état
ferraille et qui est qui a donc été
introduite en fait dans les années au
cours du 16e siècle pas les colons
espagnols et l'objectif en fait de mon
travail de thèse et de travailler en
partenariat avec les institutions
locales de Martinique de façon à pouvoir
caractériser cette population et mettre
en place en fait une gestion qui se met
appropriée à ces animaux en Martinique
pour pouvoir développer un marché
relatif et il y a même très fort
engouement autour de la de la viande de
cochon qui est une viande donc du pays
et
elle est souvent perçue comme une viande
donc qui sera naturel parce que
généralement le cochon créole est un
animal que chaque martiniquais avait
auparavant en fait chez lui et donc
c'est
participer en fait à la consommation de
cette viande c'est aussi participer à la
préservation finalement de cette
population qui à terme
deviendra une race et donc la race de
Martinique
cette tradition de Noël a été les Ardée
au fil du temps en Martinique il est
interdit aujourd'hui par exemple de tuer
son cochon à domicile il faut donc
passer par l'abattoir si la viande de
cochon reste brisée sur les tables le
soir du réveillon les Martiniquais ont
changé de comportement en adoptant
d'autres produits tels que la chair de
Dead ou le saumon s'il faut parler de la
nouvelle aujourd'hui en fait de cette
fête de Noël qui aujourd'hui de plus en
plus galvaudé parce que ce n'est plus
une célébration christique ce n'est plus
une célébration religieuse c'est une
célébration de consommation
à tel point que même la consommation a
changé on consomme plus de cochons à
consommer de la dinde on consomme plus
de boudin on va consommer du foie gras
on consomme plus la bûche on va prendre
une tarte aux pommes donc on a beaucoup
de choses qui font que du coup il y a
une espèce de
perdition de son âme une espèce de
dépérissement interne de soi
culturellement au profit d'un monde
d'extérieur qui au fond ne nous amène
que vers des désagréments puisque plus
rien ne correspond à notre mode de vie à
notre réalité plusieurs semaines avant
le jour J les gens se réunissent entre
amis que surtout en famille pour chanter
des cantiques et manger leurs porc avec
des ignames et des fois d'engol au rayon
boisson consomme le rhum local ainsi que
les penches traditionnelles le tout dans
une ambiance des plus joyeuses
après deux ans de crise sanitaire à
cause du coronavirus l'Église a son
regard sur les préparatifs dans les
foyers martiniquais il y a des chrétiens
qui se préparent dans l'intimité qui
font si lancent qui se replient
il y en a d'autres qui font le chantier
de Noël qui sont organisent pour être
dans le partage dans la rencontre dans
la solidarité dans la fraternité c'est
tout aussi bien aussi mais cette
dimension là ne doit pas empêcher
c'est-à-dire cette dimension apexterne
extérieure c'est une morsure de fait et
un peu de réjouissance il faut la faire
attention à la jouissance qui n'est pas
la même chose que la réjouissance donc
il faudra faire attention qu'on ne se
perd pas mais tout ça ça fait partie
effectivement de la préparation et de la
fête et puis il y a les fameux chantés
Noël c'est rassemblements polyphoniques
débutent en général immédiatement après
la Toussaint ou plus précisément à
partir du 1er dimanche de l'avant ce
chanté Noël fort de séries Tournelles
inspirée de quantique à Pau pairs
spirituel loulou boit la ville de son
vrai nom Louis Lucien boit la ville
décédé le 15 mars 2001 ce Foya lettres
est populaire néocardier bornabila a été
de son vivant auteur compositeur
interprète arrangeur et directeur
artistique du Grand balai de Martigny
dont il fut l'un des fondateurs loulou a
réalisé un travail colossal afin de
conforter de faire perdurer cette
tradition de fin d'année un bel héritage
patrimonial lui reconnaisse nombre de
ses disciples le nouveau la ville
j'avais laissé mon père spirituel et je
suis dans son héritier et grâce à lui
grâce à nous aussi aujourd'hui il existe
un Noël en Martinique quand nous avons
commencé à faire à chanter Noël avec le
groupe folklorique martiniquais puisque
nous avons fait un premier
enregistrement
fait un travail il n'est que de voir le
quantique le cantique de Noël quand on
voit la page de la page web par exemple
en nous souhaitant Noël quand on a le
début écoute de Noël mais je crois que
elle travaille fort il avait été fait et
il faut reconnaître un petit peu de
remettre la saison ce qui appartient à
César lui a apporté de retourner qui
était le rythme des parents qui
l'entonnait de ma Monique et de sa maman
oui il existe effectivement que les gens
sachent une fois pour toute une nuit
tonnelle c'est quoi c'est une phrase
médicale qui commence une strophe ou
qu'il a fini hein ce n'est pas une
chanson entière comme je vois maintenant
ce que je regrette pour votre mot là euh
Noël à retourner non c'est pas ça quand
j'achète Noël j'ai le coaching la
première page venez d'isez Messi et la
dernière allons-y donc mais ça m'empêche
pas entre deux strophes de faire une
retournée
la sauce alors je crois que les gens ont
peut-être confondu beaucoup de retourner
et puis Noël c'est pas c'est pas vrai
votre vrai moteur nous sommes c'est vrai
nous sommes un peu plus chaud parce que
un
mais ça nous empêche pas de dire trois
ans je sens venu ce soir ma beauté de
bien belle chose et puis après
alors je crois que
amertume parking mais je crois c'est une
évolution bon qui est de son temps on
fait avec voilà on fait avec le grand
maître du chantier de Noël qui nous a
quitté nous nous boit la ville on a eu
quand même des duos en face à face ça
c'était des très bons souvenirs parce
que ce monsieur aussi il nous a
à maintenir cette tradition et affiche
un peu de gens beaucoup de jeunes et
vieux pour permettre à d'autres de
pouvoir ouvrir je dirais ouvrir le
chemin pour d'autres puisque ça m'offrir
aussi la porte
d'aimer faire ça de venir un jour
proposer le chantier de Noël que je
connaissais à la campagne
depuis la disparition de louloubalaville
plusieurs groupes ont émergé et donc les
chantiers de Noël se multiplient aussi
bien dans les lieux publics que dans les
espaces privés ils animent également les
centres commerciaux les marchés et même
les soirées dansantes
[Musique]
je
j'ai le sentiment que je ne sens que les
choses comme ça qui compte dans la
société le côté festoyage amusement et
parallèlement il y a eu à quelques jours
une manifestation contre le Cloud et
visiblement il n'y a pas eu grand monde
que ce soit mobilisés alors que les gens
sont davantage mobilisés pour tout ce
qui est Noël et amusement mais on peut
déjà comprendre que les frustrations qui
ont été générés pendant 2 ans en criait
un besoin
innommable de s'amuser sans retenue
puisque les journal l'impression que
c'est comme si ils attendaient toute
leur vie une gourmandise qu'ils ont
envie de manger et qu'il la mange à
pleine mer à pleines
parmi les formations musicales les plus
sollicitées il y a ravine plate avec son
leader saint-berthoudart cette formation
issue d'un quartier dont elle porte le
nom au Vauclin a été l'une des premières
à reprendre le flambeau de Loulou la
philosophie
de Noël le chantait vraiment
on a pu le constater
chacun de chanter le recueil du Cantique
et puis après on met le petit piment
parce que après deux ans de sevrage
les le public retrouvent leur tradition
la tradition justement
[Musique]
parce que nous les anciens si on
ceux qui venaient nous voir ils sont
plus donc si les jeunes ne sont pas là
pour aider jeunes comme eux viennent
chanter les cantiques de Noël on perd la
tradition si la relève n'est pas assurer
on perd la tradition la dernière
question la tradition aussi en France
vous êtes souvent à Paris Région
Parisienne pour les anciens de la
capitale ah oui tout à fait tout à fait
il est incroyable de voir comment
dans l'Hexagone en publicité justement
cette tradition c'est pas de c'est pas
c'est pas du faire semblant il fait
vraiment ils sont vraiment au cœur de
la de l'objet
troubadou 9 7 2 lui est un groupe du
Lamentin connu pour ses cantiques
révisées mais aussi réputé pour ses
costumes de scène il s'impose largement
dans les soirées qui rythme l'avant
l'orchestra du succès et il faut
maintenir le cap chaque année
reconnaisse ses leaders Charles rébillon
Eve gothor et Jefferson de Free
[Musique]
bonne soirée
nous avons fait tout à l'heure
[Musique]
alors votre bateau Noël est très
important pourquoi parce qu'en fait on
s'engageait depuis 13 ans déjà à faire
perdu et cette tradition après moi la
lui permet de traverser des années et
l'importance c'est que c'est une fête
qui permet de réunir justement toutes
les classes sociales et aussi c'est
important de faire supplémentaire durer
la tradition notre culture et Noël pour
moi je parlerai de moi c'est la
meilleure fête un pour moi et il s'est
trompé
qui transmet que de la bruit de la joie
donc pour moi elle est très importante
sur le plan culturel social voilà pour
notre pays en fait la modernité a
toujours existé c'est vrai que les
ritournelles sont des choses plus ou
moins nouvelles on a l'impression que ça
n'a jamais existé vu que en discutant
avec les anciens ils ont toujours dit
qu'il y a eu des anecdotes et ce sont
les anecdotes soit anecdotes qui font le
piment du Noël il y a toujours
authentique la base qu'on connaît les
Ergon et après il y a la rituel la
méthode qui permet de mettre le piment
de chaleur parce que quand on regarde la
tonnelle ça représente c'est nous c'est
la Martinique nous faisons une musique
on peut jouer de la musique calme comme
on peut jouer de la musique très rythme
mais parce qu'on a ça dans le sens
pour registre des spectacles les plus
dynamiques bakuell est sur la première
marche du podium avec son chanteur
vedette Robert mamounza depuis le
répertoire discographie de son premier
groupe fait taille jusqu'à la dernière
production de bakwanwell ce dernier
toujours affublé de son chapeau triste
et de bakouin déverse pendant des heures
ses meilleurs qui tournait la succès et
le public en redemande toujours
[Musique]
de la
mer sont plus de la
et l'amour cela
[Musique]
c'est une famille universelle
c'est-à-dire on a des gens de Basse
Pointe
des gens de Fort-de-France Chelsea
c'est toute une réunion et quand on se
retrouve on a du mal à se quitter par la
suite parce que on passe un moment
merveilleux et il se retrouve
quelques années en arrière ou c'était
comme ça il y a même des pleurs à la fin
de la tournée puisque on va se quitter
et
cet amour qu'on a ensemble à
péter la tradition
ça c'est
le public ça se retransmet bien sûr
qu'il nous renvoie aussi donc ça fait
seulement une seule grande famille en
fait devant du podium au public
la vibration passe on sent les retours
du public et ça ça crée une cohésion
parfaite totale
[Musique]
comme ça on s'entend bien on s'embrasse
tous c'est la joie le peuple aussi il
ressent ils ont envie on les invite à
venir partager ces moments à gagner
me voir des gens qui
des grandes personnes des aînés qui
viennent me voir me dire merci merci
beaucoup parce que je me sens mieux on
sent que c'était un besoin nous bisous
salut
plus que des millions ça vaut plus que
des milliards ça c'est un cachet
extraordinaire je vous remercie tous ces
gens là pour la confiance
aussi son chemin dans les manifestations
avant Noël
d'ambiance aux yeux de son public avec
des adaptations à la sauce
traditionnelle chaque pratique à son
refaire un crayon au rythme de la
mi-temps de la maziocad de la valse
créole ou du zouk sous la direction de
Ralph péroné le faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous
chante
ta délivrance
[Musique]
le vie dans
vous êtes magnifique vous pouvez vous
applaudir
[Musique]
de son côté aime le contact direct avec
les spectateurs le chanteur désire Bonta
raconte qu'il est tombé dans la même de
la tradition à la suite du grand-prante
avec de jeunes dedans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu me disait
la mort
c'est l'esprit Noël
[Applaudissements]
Noël
dans ce groupe
ça touche féminine avec la section des
communistes et ils savent tous mettre le
public en ébullition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plus belle du monde cette nuit de
Noël ou le premier
ciel une fois le temps avec du roi non
[Musique]
si c'est Noël
on va essayer de faire ce qu'il faut
pour garder
la tradition garder ce qu'on avait avant
moi j'avais un professeur j'avais un
professeur qui s'appelle José Versol
c'est lui qui m'a donné ce que je fais
maintenant avec le buffet taillé et
maintenant on est parti là il y a eu
bijoux le bijoux qui est plus là mais
c'est lui qui doit donner ce que ce
qu'on a là maintenant on va continuer on
va essayer de faire un peu plus et voilà
on va donner ce qu'il faut aux gens la
joie au cœur le meilleur et la joie au
cœur pour ce qu'ils sont pour ceux qui
sont là quoi
musique Noël est une formation pleine de
vivacité qui propose des rythmes variés
dans les cantiques l'expérience des
musiciens et les arrangements restent
une plus-value sous la direction de
missiés
[Musique]
qui est ce grand
j'entends nos rêves
tous les jours
[Musique]
Sassa
très attachée et son examine vive les
plus belles captation s'appelle le nom
avec parfois des adaptations audacieuses
de passage de données vous de
laboratoire c'est aussi la perception
administes partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si le quantique reste le dénominateur
commun de tous ces orchestres de Noël
l'artiste chanteur compositeur et
interprète Guy métallique considéré
comme un des gardiens de cette tradition
populaire se bat encore au que les
authentiques herbes de Noël ne
disparaissent pas quelque chose qui me
gêne des choses qui me gênent comme
aujourd'hui et je me suis dit pourquoi
voulez-vous c'est une évolution
il suffit d'une fonction de seconde pour
que dans la tête
pour que aujourd'hui les choses changent
on me parle de nos outils avons-nous
sentir nos rêves nous sommes passions
Noël si vous voulez mais aujourd'hui
il y a des grands groupes les grands
groupes qui font Noël et qui font des
spectacles de Noël mais pas des chants
de Noël exactement en tant que
producteur j'ai le privilège de produits
le premier disque enregistré de Noël
avec le gaufrette martiniquais nous boit
la ville et tout
les différents 57 je crois et je suis
ouvrier tout ça c'est c'est ce point
médical
la musique en dehors c'est que en dehors
de leur sept même de Noël dans la maison
on pouvait entendre ces musiques à la
radio ça a donné un ballon
c'est comme ça nous sommes en 2022
aujourd'hui là donc c'est lundi et une
distance quand même donc le gaufrette a
pas déjà fait un certain travail avec la
maison qui était à côté de nous là à
chaque période de l'avant les
Martiniquais reprennent également la
tradition de la ribote c'est-à-dire le
passage de maison en maison d'un groupe
d'habitants en train de chanter des
cantiques et de partager des rituels
quand j'étais plus jeune nous faites pas
sur notre quartier j'ai tous les copains
pour manger on fait de La Ribot et nous
atterrissions de la famille dans
laquelle il y avait le plus d'enfants
parce que nous savions tous que c'est là
qu'il aurait eu plus à manger donc on a
eu mais autrement
ce temps et nous démarrions ce 24
décembre dès le 23 d'ailleurs on fait de
le tour du quartier à pied voilà tandis
que là non c'est le calme plein et puis
on est rentré dans des espèces de trucs
pour s'asseoir pour manger nananas c'est
alors que c'est pas donné merci habitué
donc ça ça me gêne je me souviens
lorsque j'étais à cette Marie nous a
j'avais 8 ans nous allions de 15 ans 15
et nous appelons ça le cours de Noël ça
c'est important il faut qu'on le
retienne le coût Noël que ne confondent
pas aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on appelle la
rébote hein
nous pouvons ici si vous m'avez préparez
de quoi manger donc c'est l'excès de
nourriture et le boisson entre les gars
nous faisons le coup de Noël et on
passait dans dans de Casa case avec les
cantiques enchanté enchanté enchanté il
y avait aussi il y avait aussi les
retournelles voilà le loyer d'attente et
le Noël d'aujourd'hui bon il y a c'est
vrai nous sommes dans une sorte de de je
dis de stimulation mais je crois que
l'indifférence et j'aime bien je ne suis
pas très authentique mais j'aime bien le
Noël le Noël de trois fois que j'ai
connu par rapport à celui d'aujourd'hui
le groupe troubadour 9 7 2 revendique
pour sa part une certaine modernité mais
dans s'appuyant sur la base
traditionnelle des cantiques afin de
produire de nouveaux titres chaque année
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous aimons cette période de Noël nous
aimons donner du bonheur et transmettre
aussi le savoir le savoir faire le
bonheur aussi dans les maisons parce que
avec justement votre complicité et
d'autres nous nous entrons dans les
familles et on saute Noël et puis on a
tellement attendu après ces deux ans que
je vois que
c'est une très bonne chose et c'est même
une thérapie le débat reste d'actualité
entre tradition de Noël et modernité
musicale à travers un texte publié en
mai 2022 dans les colonnes du journal en
ligne famille chrétienne l'archevêque
David Macaire va plus loin en observant
une société transformée en invité
immense et permanent en Martinique selon
lui au carnaval comme au chantez Noël
ajoute-t-il écoutez quoi qu'il arrive
quel que soit l'état de ceux qui
chantent je les ai pris du rhum ou qu'il
soit dans une chapelle
c'est que Yoka chanté
parfois il y a des paroles un peu
bizarres je ne les connais pas parce que
mon Bacal il l'a forcément mais ce que
je sais c'est que ils invoque Dieu
consciemment inconsciemment il y a
quelque chose qui qui un appel un appel
de Dieu ce divine amour ce ce grand Dieu
d'amour ce petit dieu d'amour qui est
invoqué dans cette belle tradition de
nos chanter Noël
si Jésus a envie de venir ne vous
inquiétez pas il a su venir dans les
ténèbres il a su venir dans une crèche
avec des animaux il a su venir au milieu
de Nan le bœuf et de toutes sortes de
bêtes il sera venu là où il veut y
compris dans un chant de Noël le plus
Willy je n'en doute pas un instant mais
il viendra aussi dans nos coeurs je n'en
doute pas les plus fervent catholiques
ne ratent jamais la messe de Minuit le
soir du réveillon juste avant de se
retrouver à table pour faire une paille
un moment qui précède la distribution
des cadeaux entre petits et grands puis
on se souhaite chaleureusement une
joyeuse fête
au Lamentin je mets bois joliment la
tradition est respectée Marie-Thérèse
sur nos mécriette a décoré sa maison de
guirlande pour la circonstance et la
longue table est bien garnie les
derniers plats sont au feu pendant que
l'orchestre tisseront se prépare à
entonner les champs bien connu des
voisins qui n'arrivent pas les mains
vides
[Musique]
ainsi bas le chantait Noël dans les
villes et quartiers en Martinique des
moments de partage et de convivialité
cependant pour cette année 2022 les
guirlandes de rue sont peu visibles à
l'exception de quelques villes d'autres
municipalités ont carrément renoncé aux
illuminations à l'heure des économies
d'énergie et surtout faute de budget
suffisant mais pour autant personne ne
semble vouloir se résoudre à faire une
croix sur les traditionnelles chantez
Noël et faire bombance quoi qu'il en
coûte en cette fin d'année sapés par
l'inflation alors laissez-nous vous
souhaiter une belle nuit de Noël un
formidable réveillon de la
Saint-Sylvestre et d'ores et déjà une
année 2023 remplie de bonheur
[Musique]
foot sa jolie
qui casse au meilleur
ton ciel
là
[Musique]
sainte nuit
quel bonheur
quand
[Musique]
au lit
il sont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]